foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
on Facebook and I'll censored tonight
hours turn to minutes a massive rescue
mission to find the stricken Titan Sun
enters its desperate Final Phase I'll
talk to friends and explorers on board
and ask a panel of ocean experts how
much hope remains if any also tonight is
an author and activist a world famous
intellectual of the Cornell West has
been a lifetime fighting with status quo
now he's fighting for the Oval Office he
joins me live
and the Miss England beauty pageant
plans to bring back the swimwear round
off a 20-year ban cue delight and
disdain in equal measure is this
Firebrand feminism or Stone Age sexism
or debates
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Pierce
Morgan uncensored taking risks is the
fire behind the human spirit this
ravenous desire to Adventure explore and
Conquer has taken us mere human beings
to the planet's tallest Peaks and Beyond
into space it drove us to populate and
dominate the world into this day it
bursts through the boundaries in science
and test the limits of human potential
without it frankly we're just lumps of
dull meat the five people on board the
missing Titan submersible who have gone
missing by the side of the wreckage of
the Titanic they took a major risk and
they knew what that risk was the waiver
they signed mentions potential death
three times on its front page they're
under No Illusion about what may happen
down in the murky depths of that ocean
The Pledge made clear that the
experimental vessel has not been
approved or certified by any regulatory
body any failure could cause severe
injury or death
so they knew that but they wanted to do
it anyway they were prepared to plunge
almost 4 000 meters into the dark and
icy depths in a tin camera size of a car
for a glimpse of what are the great
historic Legends the Titanic I wouldn't
do it I hate heights and I hate debts
but my God I admire those who do this
kind of thing last night I interviewed
Yannick Mickelson a close friend of
billionaire Explorer Hamish Harding
who's strapped on board
Hamish is larger than life he loves
exploration he's been to space he's been
to the deepest point of the planet he's
been to the South Pole and he's also
mentored me a lot in my career as a
Explorer and this is why I'm living
close to the North Pole to train to be a
polar Explorer and survive in the Polar
climate
it's hard not to admire someone who
succeeded in life made all his money but
chooses to spend his time at the
frontiers of human existence and of
course spend his money in the process
but not everyone agrees we live in
spiteful times fueled by vicious social
media some people seem to think that
because the people on the sub are
wealthy then the fair game just for
Mindless abuse even though they may
already be dead
Hamish Hardy tweeted one of these people
one of the bleep millionaire
billionaires on that stupid submarine is
Rich from running a private jet company
so this pathetic individual you're
literally cooking the planet alive or
meant to feel bad his stupid head has
been squashed by the righteous pressure
of the ocean imagine tweeting that to
the world that that's your thought about
people who are either trapped and may
never Escape or are dead because they
went to try to explore
can't imagine being that disgusting we
used to glorify explorers we used to
Revel in their adventure and celebrate
them
and certainly we would mourn them if
they failed in their risky challenges
but now people like to despise them and
laugh at them when they're in their most
utmost Peril and there were loads of
comments like this on Twitter in the
last couple of days maybe we can get rid
of the world's billionaires by
encouraging them to take pleasure trips
on many submarines to view the wreck of
the last mini submarine cranber
billionaire said this charming lady
keep it going she said like the old lady
just wanted to fly until they're all
gone
and a friend of this show Ash Saka an
otherwise intelligent biblical
commentator said this if the super rich
can spend 250 000 pounds of vanity
jaunts 2.4 miles beneath the ocean then
they're not being taxed enough
again what would prompt you to say that
when we don't know what's happened to
these people
when they might be dead or dying
or desperate terrified in total darkness
freezing cold the bottom of the ocean
why would your mind turn to
being envious of money they've made or
thinking this is about taxation
not to do with tax and nothing to do
with your pathetic jealousies
there's a frantic search now to Rescue
five innocent lives now is not the time
for purile abuse on Twitter or pathetic
student politics if these keyboard
Warriors had the Reigns we'd never
discover most of the world we live in or
make it to space or to the depths of the
ocean we'd still be using leeches to
cure the plague adventurers of the
people who strive to go bigger Harder
Faster and stronger than the rest of us
they take risks we wouldn't want to do
all the time
tonight we're just hours of oxygen
remaining on board that tiny vessel I
just want to say and I hope most
right-minded people would agree with me
that I hope these five adventurers
somehow survive to tell their stories
and then plan their next adventure
because they are the type of people that
really makes this world go round
well joining me is oceanographer Dr
David Gallo a close personal friend of
one of the men on board Paul Henri
nagioli by Fred Hagan who's taken the
trip to visit the Titanic wreckage twice
including with Paul Omri and sub owner
Stockton rush and by submersible expert
William Conan who says he warned or
stopped and rushed at the Titan sub
could be catastrophically unsuitable
well welcome to all of you
let me start with you uh Dr Gallo if I
may we've talked before when I was at
CNN about uh different kinds of of
situations like this but it seems a
particular crisis where you have this
tiny submersible that's gone down to
this historic site of the Titanic and we
don't know what's happened
today there was this glimmer of hope
about whether a sound that was
resonating every 30 30 minutes maybe an
SOS signal let me start with that what
did you make of that should we read too
much into it what else could that noise
be
yeah thanks Pierce uh well yesterday uh
was a gloomy day for me because I saw
the end coming the end was near and uh I
had been paying attention to this notion
that there was an explosion heard by
seismic uh device about the same time
the sub was last heard from
but then last night we had this uh news
about these this rapping sound banging
sounds and at first I thought well
here's another rumor let me see who the
source is and it's a really credible
source and it happened multiple times
and reported by multiple different uh
platforms aircrafts so it's really
boosted my uh Braille quite a bit and
I'm hoping and praying that we have a
happy ending to this
um this uh wonderful character Paul and
Marie who's done I think 30 trips down
to a Titanic he's amassed a huge
collection of stuff that he's found
there including chandeliers and so on so
it's obviously uh something he's
incredibly experienced at doing
um we're seeing a picture of the two of
you together now in fact tell me about
uh Paul on rain tell me also
someone of his experience on board is
that exactly who you need when you get a
crisis like this if they are indeed
still alive
absolutely let me clarify something when
you mentioned he amassed this collection
not personally at the time he was
working for RMS Titanic Inc and and
those are now in an artifact exhibit so
he doesn't have them personally
um yeah he's uh incredibly wise uh
battle hardened and calm as you can
imagine and pleasant as much on the deck
of a rolling ship in a hurricane as he
is sitting in a Parisian Cafe but he is
the kind of guy that can Cooley and
calmly think his way through big
problems and uh just amazing he was the
person that really put everything
together for us to find Air France 447
which many thought was uh will would
never be found so uh what's sad is that
normally he'd be on this side of the
camera with me commenting on a situation
like this but now he's on the other side
of the camera so it's a bit different
for me very different for him let me
bring in uh Fred Hagin you've been
passenger on board the Titan in uh twice
in fact with Paul Omri so you know him
better than than most you also know this
vessel extremely well what are your
thoughts right now do you believe
there's hope or are we really at the end
game do you fear
as as long as there is hope we have to
make every effort to rescue them and I
have to tell you peers thank you so much
for your eloquent introduction it
articulated exactly what I've been
telling people that it it this human
beings are differentiated by from
Animals by that Divine spark that wants
us to achieve wants us to go further and
deeper and faster and that's what
distinguishes those gentlemen and I'm
really tired of the negativity people
trying to tear Stockton here's a man
who's who's like trying to democratize
the depths he's trying to come up with a
new technology he's pushing the envelope
and he's using the wealth of businessmen
to fund what should have been funded by
the U.S government and by governments to
research the depths of the ocean because
the depths of the ocean are fundamental
to our future that's where we're going
to find the elements the power of the
green economy and I've seen the same
remarks you're talking about even on my
social media feed people talking about
how could we spend this money to rescue
you these billionaire businessmen well
I'm going to tell you why we do that we
would do it even if they were homeless
children sitting in a cave because the
world arises to that challenge and the
poor we will have with us only Jesus
said that and that we can't go to a
better Source than that and I would also
say that this is an opportunity for the
government to pay tribute to the private
Enterprise that is driving the
technology that will be required to
explore Inner Space much as private
Technologies exploring outer space so
kudos to Stockton for taking that risk
for moving forward and you know it's
like the Wright brothers when they took
that first flight and they released from
the bonds of Earth they had no backup
they had no safety plan if they'd have
crashed and gotten killed they still
would have done the first to fly he is
the first person who's trying to
democratize the depths and my hat's off
to them let me ask you from you've been
on time so what are the conditions
likely to be like if they're still alive
and this sound this banging sound is
indeed them expressing an SOS a call for
help what would those conditions be like
inside there right now if they are right
down near the Titanic
well it's horrifying for me to think of
when I last year when I was down with ph
you know the titanium nose it it seeps
in the the icy cold because the water
down there is at a freezing level and it
condenses and there I'm there would be
sitting on the mats in the back of the
submersible but it's a very small space
so the five of them must be laying side
by side and you know if pH is sending
these messages on a regular basis he's
doing so because and he's doing it every
30 minutes to establish that this is a
man-made pattern and he's doing it in
because it's also giving those five
people something to occupy their
thoughts and the rest of the time he
would be having all of them sleeping
because they would consume the least
amount of oxygen so they're resting
they're sleeping and then they're every
hour they're they're getting up and
they're knocking on the shell of that
submersible that's what I hope is
happening and that's what PH would
and in terms of the amount of oxygen
they have we're told that by about 10
o'clock tomorrow morning UK time the
amount of oxygen Runs Out is that your
understanding
that is my understanding and it would be
heartbreaking to consider that a man as
warm and wonderful and dynamic his pH
could be lost to the world you know I
will personally feel impoverished and
and I got to tell you if you could if I
could make a personal comment I've said
this before you know I feel convicted
because last year pH when we got down to
the Titanic he actually sat in that
titanium nose it's freezing cold it's
full of condensation and he had slippers
on which everyone works at me I took
these soft shoot Uggs with soft sold
Uggs with sheepskin lining I meant to
buy him a pair before he went and I keep
thinking of them down there in this
cramped claustrophobic quarters with his
feet Frozen and I just you know I can't
forgive myself for the simple Act of not
sending him the boots that I intended I
know that sounds absolutely no it
doesn't actually it sounds very it
sounds very human and very caring and
exactly how I would feel in that
situation and it's it's the whole thing
is heartbreaking it's situation these
are people who who love what they do and
and are part of history when they go
down and find stuff and and bring it
back up to the world to see but there is
a another side to this yes if I could
interject it just one thing I'd like to
say because you have referenced the
people that are talking about how
outrageous it is for us to spend this
time and money I want to remind those
people that 93 of the taxes paid in this
country are paid by businesses through
tax and remittances and we are now
returning that favor by seeking them out
and we would do that even if they were
impoverished but we do that because in
the Western World we put no price on
human life
listen I find that that politics of Envy
stuff just ridiculous in a situation
like this but let me bring in William
because William Conan you actually in
2018 you all want a 40 submersible
experts who wrote a letter to the Ocean
Gate CEO Stockton Rush warning that the
experimental Titan sub did not meet
industry standards and I understand that
you you stand by every word of that
letter today obviously you don't want to
be Vindicated as such but is this what
you feared May one day happen
yeah Paris was a uh it is a difficult
situation we have over here it's uh
right now what's uh going out in the
field uh you know we the the ocean has
the ability to Humble us uh puny humans
out here
uh it is very unforgiving and
from the perspective of the industry
that makes these vehicles
um
we are humbled by the complexity of what
it takes to go down there
what we have learned over 50 years is
Humanity has learned how to safely
explore the bottom there are submarines
that go down uh 6 000 meters and more uh
every week I mean we have been doing
that for decades
we have found out how to do this safely
it takes time it is expensive
going deep is difficult and so as an
industry we have we have a North star
that we follow you might say look it's
it's it's parametric you're just
following old routines but it is working
it has allowed us to operate for 50
years without a single event
and that is to uh follow a a framework
of certification that we have built up
it's an international framework we know
it works
and that has stood Us by this is
possible and this is safe am I
understand
my understanding is that the Titan sub
was only certified to reach depths of up
to 1300 meters underwater but of course
the Titanic is nearly 4 000 meters which
is considerably further so do you do you
believe if you're being honest that it
was irresponsible to try and go this far
down with the Titan
uh it is not possible to say what the uh
what the actual parameters are appears
and and that's part of the the the the
the issue of not going through a
certification and I just want to add to
that uh the process certification sounds
like red tape but what it really is is
teamwork uh and it involves
International organizations that have
rules and regulations and inspectors and
Engineers that scrub the design that
verify how it's built that witness the
testing and what that does is it does
give a whole team of seasoned engineers
and professionals that add
to ensure nothing is missed that
everything is in order because when
you're out there under these conditions
father Neptune here does not give a lot
of seconds your concerns in that letter
in 2018 they were that the Titan did not
meet the requirements to do this kind of
voyage right
the so the origin I wrote the letter uh
I talked to Stockton about it and it did
came about because we do organize the
only conference on submersibles we
invite experts from around the world
once a year and in 2018 at the end of
the conference a number of people said
you know this is very very risky 4 000
meters for five people uh doing it
experimental without following uh our
accepted rules of of of of design and
safety is so risky what should we do uh
remaining silent didn't seem an option
we are all a bunch of nerds and
engineers in some way we have a very
strong feeling and passion for uh as
engineers in general duty of care
and there are certain things that uh
we must take care of because it is not
reasonable for
normal citizens
we're running at a time but William just
do you believe that there is any hope
that they will survive this
yes yes there is uh I agree we have to
make all the efforts as long as we are
it is it is an issue the fact that we
have completely lost communication early
on and we don't know where it is and
right now uh searching a small
submersible like that in a White Field
is so difficult but if we can find them
we can hook up to them and bring them to
surface let's leave it there on that
positive note and hope that that is
positivity which is met and borne out by
events in the next uh in the next few
hours well no I'm sadly by tomorrow
morning uh the oxygen runs out so
there's a horrible ticking clock on this
and we can only hope and pray that they
do come forward and there is a miracle
thank you both all three of you very
much indeed for joining I appreciate it
uh well it says that next the lightning
of the low Miss England is to bring back
the swimwear round supporters say it's
empowering critics say it's sexist one
of those critics will debate that with a
former Miss USA next
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
contest has revealed it could restore
its bikini competition after 20 years of
self-censorship the pageant used to
feature a swimwear around for budding
Beauty to Showcase their physical
fitness but it was banned in 2002 amid
claims of sexism well earlier this year
Miss Northern Ireland ditched its bikini
around other concerns it was distracting
from the true meaning of the contest
which suggests to me they didn't
understand the true meaning of the
contest but Angie Beasley the director
of his England says she's refusing to
bow down to the woke Brigade as she
mulls the big decision adding it's great
to be empowering women to feel confident
in their own skin so this is Firebrand
feminism or just Stone Age sexism and
what frankly is so offensive about
bikinis well I'm joined by the former
Miss USA Sarah Rose Summers uh Nirvana
Knoll the former Miss Croatia and the
feminist campaign and current Miss North
London I've given her that title Julian
bentle all right Julie let me start with
you miss North London which I'm sure you
would have wanted you'd ever rented um
what's your problem with this I I never
understood why they took it away I
thought the whole point of beauty
pageants was the name on the tin
suggests it was about physical Beauty
and we got to celebrate the beautiful
female form who cares
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
celebrating Beauty there's nothing wrong
with women's own definition of beauty
the problem is pitting women against
each other competitively and Men
deciding who is conventionally
attractive
in the sense of the very sexist
stereotypes
under the cost of and women used to
watch them of course but there's no why
are you singles there's little Point
putting
that because there's little Point using
women as a smoke screen to suggest that
because of course I agree that women
have the right to do what they wish with
their own bodies there's no point
suggesting that this is about women and
women's empowerment and agency when this
comes from men this comes from the
directive that women's worth should be
measured with conventional Beauty like I
say I have no issue with women
let me challenge you on this what is
wrong with celebrating conventional
Beauty I used to love watching Miss
World nursings absolutely
look the competitiveness
of these Beauty competitions is sexism
on stereo they're competitions to see
users
it's the whole point of it women lose
and women win and this is exactly how
women are socialized to feel worthless
compared
you don't believe this beauty standard
that is set by Men Without sexism we
wouldn't have missed last time I checked
and also if you think about what happens
in these competitions absolutely there
are so many women last time I checked
millions of women watched these
competitions on TV too they love them
it's irrelevant as it is what I'm
talking about is the because it's about
the message that it sends to girls to
women in society that this is something
that oh you have to wear loads of
clothes otherwise otherwise and not to
men so you can only be in a beauty
pageant if you wear head to toe clothing
that covers all your flesh it sounds
like something out of North Korea Saudi
Arabia themselves
no no beauty pageants in and of
themselves
are a symbol of sexism I'm not
suggesting Banning them I'm not
suggesting locking up those that
organize them or profit from them such
as Donald Trump of course that
well-known pro-feminist man who owned
Miss Universe the stories about the
sexual harassment sexual assault and
terrible treatment of women in these
pageants have been circulating for
decades
all right all of the reports from women
about what happens to them during these
patterns let me go to someone who won uh
Miss USA and Miss Universe Sarah Rose
Summers Sarah you've been laughing away
listening to this because apparently
you're you're a tormented victim and
this is demeaning and sexist and male
things like well you basically implied
that it's only men like me who are you
know being sexist pigs and watching it
well okay you implied it was a male
issue that because men are objectifying
women like Sarah so Sarah did you feel
did you feel objectified and a victim
I did not I think it's just so important
in this feminist female empowerment
movement that we support each other's
dreams and goals and aspirations and no
one ever forced me to compete in Miss
Nebraska USA Miss USA Miss Universe that
was something I chose to do and I
started competing in pageants without a
swimsuit competition
um back when I was just 10 years old I
was super shy it brought me public
speaking skills interview skills taught
me confidence how to hold myself on a
stage and in a swimsuit and long term I
believe the swimsuit competition is a
positive for Miss contestants
specifically because it really did teach
me a healthy lifestyle it taught me to
long-term sustain you know I never
neglected My Sweet Tooth I love my
sweets but I found ways I enjoyed moving
my body and that's not something that
came natural to me either I think that's
so important when people hear that I'm
Pro swimsuit competition they instantly
think oh well you know look at you you
clearly you don't have to work for it by
any means well that is completely false
genetics have definitely been against me
I've watched my mom yo-yo diet and diet
her whole life and so I knew firsthand
that I wanted to be proactive and stay
fit so I enjoy workout classes and
things of that nature so for myself and
most everyone it's a very close-knit
group of women you know we're all very
like-minded we have big lofty goals and
our very philanthropic focused so some
of my best friends I've met through
pageantry and I would say that all of us
would unanimously agree that the
competitions that are in Miss USA Miss
Universe have only strengthened our
confidence okay
I like that and I I think that's exactly
what my feedback has been I've actually
judged one of these things Miss UK I
think it was
um eventually yeah I did interesting I
thoroughly enjoyed it I thought it was a
wonderful judges panel yeah I thought it
was a wonderful judges panel was fully
made of women as well right I mean I
just thought it was a celebration of of
feminist empowerment frankly uh Ivana
you are not exactly shy uh we see a lot
of you on your Instagram
um and you're wearing I think your
swimsuit as we speak uh what do you make
of this I mean do you think there's any
any Merit to the argument that perhaps
it is a bit demeaning for women to in a
beauty pageant have to wear swimsuits
their peers I cannot even think I I'm
not I cannot believe in 2023 we'll
discussed about this uh I'm a bikini
owner of SSC and first of all bikini is
a part of life even every Grandma Grand
grandpa has a bikini guys wearing bikini
bye guys are not sexual anxiety wearing
men's shorts it's totally different
um men can be a hormonal crazy about
women very completely Legends and
covered it doesn't need to be bikini for
sexualism you know he can say oh this
girl is hot even full dress it's how we
behave and how we allow guys to behave
with us if I say hey I don't care about
your hormones I'm very bikini and I want
to be respected I'm respected and girl
who is coming to our competition for
Miss World she need to be confident and
she don't care about guy who is thinking
with hormones I I don't think this girl
should even be in the competition
because if she is shy and she's afraid
to be sexualized then this poor girl
should be in a living room and watch on
TV screen I completely agree let me
bring Julie back Julie isn't this a
point you don't have to enter these
things they are a competition I used to
judge Britain's Got Talent and America's
Got Talent we'd have all sorts of people
on uh with all sorts of talents now no
one's forcing them to be there there's
no gun to these young ladies heads
they're on it because they want to show
off their beauty and last time I checked
we are allowed to celebrate the
beautiful female form as indeed we are
to celebrate the beautiful male form I
mean you're looking at it
I mean I had had your producer told me
that I would be debating with two women
about this I would have chosen not to
come on the program because I will not
argue with women about the choices they
make my argument is against the men that
set these conventional beauty standards
that impose this these standards on
girls and women growing up most of whom
feel that they are being judged and that
they are being demeaned they eventually
just have the complete opposite more or
less than their own understanding
competitiveness Between Women is the
worst thing possible when actually we
need to stick together so I wouldn't
have chosen to come on the program had I
known I was debating with these two
women because my argument isn't with
them it's with the men that uphold these
standards right but what you
conveniently ignoring is we've had two
women who've Taken part in these
pageants who both say that there's no
problem the women and all enjoy being on
it they'd like a bit of friendly
competition they're all supportive of
each other they don't feel remotely
bothered about men objectifying them
because as many women watch it as men I
really don't see what the problem is and
there are thousands and thousands of
testimonies from women all over the
world since the 1960s that have been in
beauty pageants that talk about hideous
misogynistic treatment by men where they
talk about rape and sexual assault
sexual harassment and being thrown away
and discarded once they get to the age
of 27 which is the age limit and being
told that they're over the hill so there
are stories that we haven't heard
tonight and I would tell your your
viewers maybe go and do a little bit of
Google research and have a look at this
okay so let me ask you this then what
how do you feel then about public
beaches High streets where women March
around in bikinis especially my issue
isn't with with my issue isn't with
nakedness on nudity my issue is with the
value placed upon
women competing with each other
for who has the perfect in the eyes of
sexist men that judge women
honestly
with nakedness Julian I think it's such
a lame thing to say that it's just
sexist men that watch these things they
don't I know loads of women well it's
true love watching cutie pageants and
admiring the beauty as they do by the
way when they buy women's magazines and
see beautiful women on the cover I don't
want to hold women up
Julie I make no apology for admiring the
beautiful female form including yourself
and my two others I wouldn't ask you two
peers I know I'm just offering my my
appreciation of Miss North London
is that okay
and Julie I think it's important to note
like I had said earlier that my panel
judges was solely women that were
successful in their industry so I wasn't
shredding my stuff up there answering on
stage questions to men as you keep
mentioning thankfully
um
but I would say honestly Sarah I would
say just because men like watching
beauty pageants doesn't make us all a
bunch of sexist pigs you can appreciate
a beautiful woman of course not in the
most
non-sexisting I admire Beauty I'd like
it in all guises I like a beautiful
Arsenal football player as much as I
admire a beautiful woman
thank you Julie we've reached a point of
agreement I think or at least
acknowledgment I'm allowed to like
beautiful things lovely to speak to all
three of you thank you very much indeed
well I'm saying next this is a real oh
this is a real gear change Dr Cornell
West uh haven't spoken to him for many
years but was one of my favorite guests
when I used to work at CNN who spent his
life fighting the status quo he's now
fighting for the Oval Office and he
joins me live next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back we're Dr Cornell West has
done it all Harvard Professor
philosopher social justice Pioneer even
appeared in two of The Matrix movies
because his way his next job will Top a
lot president of the United States as
his Twitter announcement shows he's
ready for a fight
do we have what it takes
we shall see
but some of us are going to go down
fighting Go Down Swinging with style and
a smile accenting the best in you and
trying to tease out the best in me let's
do it together
well that actually makes me want to vote
for him immediately Dr Corner West the
green party residential candidate joins
me from Orange County in California Dr
West what a pleasure to speak to you
again
my dear brother I appreciate you having
me here and it's been a long time a long
time brother Tavis in the dialogue but
God bless you and your loved ones I'm
gonna say you've aged better than I have
uh and I I've got to say if all else
fails Dr West you'll always have a job
doing the intro to my show each night
with that voice
we both are blessed and we'll we are
still here in our right minds or brother
this world is uh quite a place to be
right now let me ask you let me ask you
about that actually uh just off the top
what do you make of the state of the
world we've gone through a very uh
disastrous pandemic a cost of living
crisis we haven't seen for many decades
uh we've had some appalling racial uh
situations like the George Floyd murder
uh we've had obviously a war raging in
Ukraine now in Europe again where are we
as a planet you think
let me tell you the truth brother the
history of the species is one in which
we're so wretched it's too many forms of
domination too much hatred too much
greed but we always have moments of
interruption we try to broaden those
interruptions with love Justice deep
integrity and solidarity with foreign
working people so I you know we could
beat the great Lawrence Stern we can
read Cervantes and see oh my God we've
always been such a wretched species so
much so much ugliness so much
overwhelming suffering and yet they will
not have the last word that's where
courage comes in that's where compassion
comes in that's where democracy comes in
my brother
a lack of moral courage in world leaders
right now just generally
absolutely
there's no doubt about it no doubt not
just leaders but I think too often you
get uh
professionals and educated people who
are so obsessed with material success
and they give up on moral and spiritual
greatness you know and I know that uh
you know the legacy of Martin Luther
King Jr Rabbi heshold and Dorothy Day
and in your own country RH Thomas
Stewart Hall of Jacqueline Rose I mean
these are truth tellers who cut Against
the Grain no one's perfect but we need
exemplars of genuine compassion and
courage that goes far beyond just
obsession with money status spectacle
and image but we live in a world in
which everything's commodified
everybody's for sale everything is for
sale The Superficial and the surface
replace these substantive and most
importantly the courageous so yes it's
this it's a lot of spiritual decaying in
the United States we got Trump leading
us towards Civil War Biden leading us
toward World War III connected to
Ukraine and China we need voices it be
on the hatred get beyond the Revenge but
look at the world through the lens of
those friends for known called The
Wretched of the earth poor and working
people I don't care what color or
country or sexual orientation or gender
I'm talking about their humanity and too
often the organized greed at the top is
leading us to destruction my brother
you've been us very powerful I have to
say you've been very outspoken about
Ukraine uh you want to see peace uh in
that uh War but how does peace look like
if you're Ukrainian You've Had Vladimir
Putin illegally invade your country a
democratic country seizing land which
belongs to you how is there any peace to
be achieved if Ukraine in my opinion
quite rightly don't want to give an inch
of any of this land to the Russians
well one I think we always begin with
solidarity with the suffering and that
is the suffering of our precious
brothers and sisters in the Ukraine but
we have to understand this in the larger
backdrop brother you know and I know
that United States promised Russia they
would not move one inch forward Russia
by means of NATO now 13 former countries
associated with Soviet Union are part of
NATO there's missiles
into targeting Russia right near the
borders you know what I know again if
there were missiles in in Mexico and
Canada
who were operated sponsored by Russia or
China the United States would blow and
blow them into Smithereens overnight
that's how Empires function in that
regard so that yes that invasion is
Criminal yes that invasion is wrong and
immoral but at the same time NATO as an
instrument of U.S Global power and
Imperial policy pushed them against the
wall they did have a they were close to
a ceasefire agreement in March of 2022
and yet United States
did not give the green light so we've
got to really just to pin you down on my
question
how do they now do a peace deal that
doesn't involve Ukraine giving up land
that they are determined not to give up
well no once you have deceased fire my
brother and you got to bring in the
Chinese you got to bring in the African
leaders you got to bring in Ukraine you
got to bring in the Turks those who have
played a role in trying to promote the
ceasefire you then move through
diplomatic processes so that there's
fairness in the Diplomatic process but
you've got to stop the fighting you've
got to stop the war and it becomes more
and more proxy war against America and
Russia on the way to nuclear exchange on
the way to World War III
this is madness we've got to be able to
have constraints in this regard but yes
you're ranked the suffering of our
precious Ukrainian brothers and sisters
is very real and that's one of the
reasons why it's got to stop immediately
120 billion dollars of U.S taxpayer
money already gone there and of course
Martin Luther King used to say that the
uh the bombs dropped in Vietnam land and
ghettos and reservations and poor
working-class communities of any color
so the military expands and we get
pulled back on Social Services social
programs for the poor not just in the
United States but unfortunately this is
more and more true around the world my
brother Dr West I can talk to you for
hours and I'm sorry we've run out of
time I want to wish you all the best
with your campaign because the campaign
the race needs somebody like you with
your intellect with your passion I think
with your moral courage and your honesty
uh and your conviction for things I've
always enjoyed talking to you I have
again tonight please come back on again
soon I appreciate it no uh you call it
I'll definitely be back but you stay
strong my brother good to see you not to
us all the best all right and since the
next controversial social media
Superstar Andrew Tate and his brother
appear and children Romania facing
charges of rape and human trafficking
well here they responded next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk the U.S Coast
Guard says they need to have hope as the
search for the missing Titanic sub
continues and no handouts for mortgage
holders says Jeremy Hunt as Brits wait
with baited breath for yet another
interest rate rise and Twitter owner
Elon Musk Brands the term cisgender a
slur that's all on the talk at nine
foreign
[Music]
Associates of Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
so
Kevin do you identify as a CIS man
no I don't even know what it means uh
yes and if I was called it I wouldn't be
offended although I know it can
occasionally be a term of abuse can
occasionally well it's quite interesting
so uh this guy on Twitter uh objects to
being called CIS and cisgender so a
bunch of trans activists then bombard
him with calling him and cisgender
right and using it as an attacking thing
and Elon Musk got involved and he said
but actually the word CIS and cisgender
are deemed slurs on Twitter they used in
the harassing way and it was interesting
so JK Rowling then responded to this
this is ideological language signifying
belief in the unfulcifiable concept of
gender identity of a perfect right to
believe in unprovable Essences that may
or may not match the sexed body but the
rest of us have a right to disagree and
to refuse to adopt your jargon that to
me is crucial why should I have to go
along with being called something I
don't even understand or recognize I'm a
man no I'm not a cisgender bloke or
whatever no you don't but also if you're
Elon Musk and you say you believe in
free speech why do you ban that when you
don't for instance lots of cases of uh
of racism and he allows far-right groups
to run them off
he is trying to ban all that as well
no he took out he took over Twitter and
he relaxed the controls and the
regulations he allowed certain people
back on who were conservative
commentators and groups who had no doubt
either been banned or Shadow banned
which is even more kind of weird it's
interesting by a bunch of wokies at
Twitter and they're not all racist head
bangers at all I don't think this is
enough of a slur to ban it I think this
was a bit of a mistake on elon's part
but I do think the word cisgender or
says
wait you see I don't think right
you say no well we're not having or not
having the transact of this deciding
what language can or can't be used in a
derogatory way why has he gone off on
this and he turns a blind eye or
permitting yeah
see but politically he's not actually
right wing he's a Bernie Sanders guy
historically right I mean he's not that
right now look he's all over the place
for his own commercial interests the
Republicans in the middle I think he's
trying to find a balance of where Free
Speech lies I really do think he's well
I think he's shooting on Twitter like
his own like sort of personal toy uh
would you know if you buy it you can
play with it but I don't think this is
enough of an offensive World we've just
seen Hunter Biden the son of the
president has now been uh charged on
several offenses about his taxes that
all came from the laptop yeah which was
suppressed by twitch if you remember New
York Post story exposing my laptop was
actually banned by Twitter from being
seen by anybody yeah and that's the kind
of thing that was going on before Elon
Musk bought it he's saying that's wrong
yeah but look we can condemn that and it
should have been allowed you know New
York Times very reputable it should have
been allowed to be there I mean if you
can criticize that and sway the election
and we can also yeah and we can also
criticize mosque again here on saying
right Sis's back I think he's right he
just needs to distance himself I want to
get an interview with Elon Musk he knows
I do
obviously I've interviewed him several
times he's now been charged in Romania
with rape human trafficking or forming
an organized crime group sexually
exploited women his brother Tristan two
associates also faced charges they all
deny the allegations this is what Andrew
Tate said outside called today
but I would like to say
thank you to all the supporters we have
around the world regardless of what the
mainstream media keeps saying and the
lies they're trying to purport we get
tens of thousands of messages from
people every single day supporting us
and they understand that we're not the
first affluent wealthy men who have been
unfairly attacked in our in our
situation unfortunately it happens quite
often so in fact it denial emphatic
defenses expect nothing else from him
but what do we make of this case can you
get a fair trial in Romania well we'll
we'll see it it should be dealt with on
the facts but I don't think I'll be
joining any vigils outside the Romanian
Embassy or suggesting omniscient
National make them a prisoner of
conscience
he's a deeply unsympathetic character
because he's probably doesn't make him
real spreading that's that's what I was
saying doesn't make him innocence
I actually think he is innocent and I
think this is more about reputation
damage than anything because I think
they've taken so long to even charge him
and he's always proclaimed his innocence
and I think if he was guilty of all of
these things you wouldn't be the world I
will be very interested to see this
trial actually yeah see what actually
comes out and let Justice take its
course yeah thank you Pat appreciate it
that's it from me whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]